معنا من عمان لواء فايز الدويريا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لو وفائزه اهلا بك
يعني بين الروايه الروسيه البيلاروسيه
وبين ما يقوله الجانب الاوكراني وايضا
الامريكي كيف ترى الهجوم المضاد من حيث
النتائج
يعني الان الهجوم المضاد استنادا الى
التصريحات الرسميه الاوكرانيه
وبعض الاشارات والايماءات الغربيه
الهجوم المضاده الرئيسي لم يبدا بعد فقط
المرحله التمهيديه وهي المرحله التي تكون
اهم اولوياتها عمليات استطلاع بالقوه
جاستن نبض تحديد نقاط الضعف احداث
اختراقات توسيع هذه الاختراقات لانشاء ما
يسمى بموضع القدم من اجل انجاح الهجوم
المضاد الرئيسي اخر تصريحات غربيه امريكيه
وحتى مركز دراسات الحرب يقول هناك ان
القوه الرئيسيه لجراند ارمي او البنك
الرئيسي للقوات الاوكرانيه لم يتم الزج به
رغم ذلك المرحله التمهيديه استعاده
السيطره على ما يقارب 200 كيلو متر مربع
في مختلفه في دونيس فيزا بروجيا وفي خرسون
وبالتالي اذا اعتمدنا هذه المقاربه نعم
تم تحقيق انجازات لكنها لا ترقى الى
المستوى الذي يسمع بشن الهجوم الرئيسي
المضعن سياده اللواء الحرب من اولى
ضحاياها الحقيقه ومن الصعوبه بمكان الوقوف
على الاعداد الحقيقيه للضحايا والقتل لكن
قبل قبل ايام او قبل اسابيع ظهرت تقييمات
استخباريه غربيه تتحدث عن خساره الجيش
الاوكراني 20% تقريبا من قدراته خلال
الايام الاولى من الهجوم المضاد اليوم
يتحدث الرئيس الروسيه عن مقتل اكثر من 25
الف جندي اوكراني خلال هذا الهجوم المضاد
اذا وضعنا هذه الى جوار تلك هل يمكن ان
نخرج بصوره اكثر وضوحا لما يجري على الارض
للاسف
التصريحات الروسيه والاوكرانيه مبالغ جدا
فيها اذا
امسكنا باله حاسبه
وسجلنا الخسائر التي تحدث عنها كلا
الجانبين والحقها بالجانب الاخر قد يكون
الان جيوشهم اصبحت على وجه وشكل خروج من
العمليات العسكريه لهذا السبب انا شخصيا
لا اتبنى الارقام التي تصدر من هنا وهناك
لانه مبالغ جدا بها هل من قبيل المبالغه
سياده اللواء ما ذكره رئيس بيلاروسيا من
ان الناتو فعلا يسعى لضم الاراضي الغربيه
من اوكرانيا الى بولندا هل هذا من قبيل
المبالغه ام من قبيل التقييم الذي ياخذ
القبريات الاخذ والرد
لا انا لا اعتبر ذلك يعني فقط مبالغه
اعتبر ذلك كلام خارج الصندوق بالمطلق لانه
الحديث عن تجزئه اوكرانيا وضم غرب
اوكرانيا الى الى بولندا وحديث الرئيس انه
لا وجود لاوكرانيا على الخارطه هذا الكلام
يعني عوده عقارب الساعه الى عقود وقرون
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يحدث هذا الشيء الى
الان هدف الغرب انا هنا لا ادافع عنه
ابقاء اوكرانيا موحده لتكون جزء من الناتو
وتعتبر حاجز صدح اضافي امام
الدب الروسي وبالتالي لا يمكن ان اتبنى
هذا الكلام في جمله واحده علينا ان نتذكر
بدايه نشوء دوله المانيا عند تحت مسمى
بروسيارك اين هي بروسيا بروسيا الان تقع
في بولندا اذا الخريطه السياسيه اوروبا
سعاد النظر بها لربما ثبات ايضا اللقاء
الذي جمع الرئيس الروسيه بوتين بالرئيس
لوكاشنكا وكان هناك حديث واضح عن ان فاجنر
تريد وفق تصريحات الرئيس لوكاشنكا الذهاب
الى بولندا تحديدا ومناطق داخل فولندا ما
مدى واقعيه هذا الحديث
يعني الان هذا رئيس دوله واستضاف خمسه الى
ثمانيه الاف من باقنر وبالتالي اصبح لا
يسيطر عليهم لماذا استقبلهم هذا السؤال
البديهي بالامس كان هناك تقارير واضحه انه
من بريجل القائد بانه يتم التحضير لاعاده
توظيف جهد فاجنر في افريقيا فهل ناخذ
بكلام الرئيس لوكاشنكا ام بكلام بريكولجن
نفسه الذي يريد اعاده توظيف فاجنر في في
افريقيا انا اعتبر هذا الكلام من باب
التهويل ومن باب محاوله ابتزاز الغرب بان
دوله الاتحاد لديها ما تفعله شكرا جزيلا
لك اللواء فايز دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي حدثتنا من عمان